hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer
runde
wer bin ich ganz spontan mit wir haben
read me zeit freunde aber wir haben uns
gedacht wir nehmen eine runde wer wenig
auf und ich würde sagen hier fangen an
mit dem aufkleben von dem bildschirm
event genau sehen wird sehr fehlen
dass er mit der canon legria du muss
darauf achten dass es nicht irgendwie
explodiert ich hab die fresse wir wollen
wetten die krücken die schau an
update so ich habe er realisiert das
video über den laden gekommen und
geblieben war seit jahren darüber dass
bei mir genau das hält das fast das zeug
auch kein schnickschnack ist männlich
will ich endlich schwimmen
also habe ich mehr wir haben gesagt wenn
man eine abo fragen zu gast war in
freiburg habe ich mehr als 200.000
abonnenten habe ich mehr als 1 million
abonnenten nein
okay bin ich männlich
habe ich mir 200.000 abonnenten ja bin
ich ja also ich brauche heute videos ja
ok wohl in köln
nee mach ich deutsch-deutsche schliff
verpasst wurde gehts ja wie es gelaufen
ok wo ich wohne in deutschland oder erst
habe ich mehr als 500.000 abonnenten
main
das hat eine zweite arbeitsphase mache
ich gaming videos ja wenn ich komm
kräfte nicht computer video schon wählen
würde sie nicht wieder passiert
ich bin was ich war mental ich wäre ja
noch heute ja ja ich glaube schon
ziemlich di maria der über eine million
blonde haare
aber ich bin männlich
er ist männlich noch blonde heute bin
ich oft auf so youtube ersetzen
was meinst mit youtube events ja im
video dance music video direkt auf die
bühne
ich glaube nicht aber ich habe jetzt
nicht alles von der wind schon
mitbekommen
ich würd mal sagen hören bin ich im
netzwerk wird ich mit einem anderen
youtuber zusammen
die firma eine ziemlich okay bin ich
bemüht über zusammen dann nochmal
zusammengefasst ich bin männlich
ich habe mehr als 200.000 aber unter
einer million ja ich habe nicht hab ich
schwarze haare und ich bin männlich
aufkochen machen
ich bin ich jemand der in seinen videos
oft ausrastet wenn ich immer der sehr
viel lacht
in den videos jetzt oder in einem video
auf jeden fall bin ich
sie gibt es gibt immer ein tipp du
machst den kanal nicht alleine
ach so ich mache keine löcher leine ich
habe mir ein 200.000 ja bin ich
05 nein du musst du kämpfen
gebäude das sind die leute die wir
hatten nicht aktuell und er hatte sich
selber solchen fall dann könnt ihr gerne
bewertung erlassen und wir sehen uns
dann irgendwann wieder